[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und willkommen
alles Wichtige aus der Welt des Sports
gibt's von Norbert Lehmann schön guten
Abend auch von mir wir schauen unter
anderem ausführlich auf diese
Themen Absturz einer Militärmaschine die
Ukraine habe den russischen Transporter
abgeschossen behauptet Moskau und so
irtümlich 65 ukrainische Kriegsgefangene
an Bord
getötet Streik XXL fast se Tage lang
müssen die Fahrgäste der Bahn um ihre
Zugverbindungen bangen und der
Tarifkonflikt scheint völlig
festgefahren starke Nerven tolles Spiel
Alexander SF lässt dem Weltranglisten
zweiten Carlos alkaras keine Chance und
kämpft sich so ins Halbfinale der
Australian
Open seit genau 700 Tagen herrscht in
der Ukraine Krieg heute hat Russland den
Absturz einer Militärmaschine auf
eigenem Territorium gemeldet an Bord
sollen 65 ukrainische Kriegsgefangene
gewesen sein auf dem Weg zu einem
Gefangenenaustausch niemand habe
überlebt es gibt noch viele offene
Fragen und Widersprüche schauen wir
genauer darauf bei dem Flugzeug handelt
es sich um eine Transportmaschine vom
Tip ilushin
il76 der Flieger war heute morgen nah
der grenznahen elgorot unterwegs dann
wurde er offenbar beschossen etwa 70 km
nordöstlich beim Ort jablonovo stürzte
das Flugzeug ab mehr jetzt von Sebastian
e Wrackteile brechen weg vom Flugzeug
dann ein Feuerball diese Aufnahmen
sollen den Absturz der russischen
Militärmaschine in der Nähe des Dorfes
jablanava
zeigen wir haben gerade ein rotes
längliches Flugobjekt gesehen dann
hörten wir eine Explosion und ein roten
Blitz das
war Bilder die das Wrack zeigen sollen
starke schrapnelleinwirkung Zeichen für
einen Abschuss mit einer bodenluftrakete
Moskau beschuldigt die
Ukraine heute um 11 verübte das Kiever
Regime einen Terroranschlag bei dem ein
russisches Militärflugzeug abgeschossen
wurde das auf dem Weg von jakalowski
nach belgorot war um ukrainisches
Militärpersonal zu einem Gefangenen
Austausch zu
transportieren die russischen Behörden
bestätigen niemand habe den Absturz
überlebt 65 ukrainische Gefangene und
neun russische Militärs seien an Bord
gewesen der ukrainische Geheimdienst
äußert sich am Abend auf seiner Homepage
wir haben derzeit keine zuverlässigen
und vollständigen Informationen darüber
wer oder wie viele Personen an Bord des
Flugzeugs waren das Transportflugzeug so
viel ist klar war eine ilusin 76 unklar
warum Russland nur Gefangene mit diesem
teuren und großen Flugzeug transportiert
haben
soll
häufig passiert es aber so dass man das
kombiniert dass man an den Seiten wenn
es nicht gerade um Fallschirms Springer
absetzen geht dass man an den Seiten äh
die Sitze nutzt und dann in der Mitte im
Frachtraum dann
militärische Fracht
mitfördert was war an Bord der eliosin
76 Gefangene militärisches Gerät oder
beides auch Stunden nach dem Unglück
lässt sich das nicht unabhängig
überprüfen genauso wenig wer für den
Abschuss verantwortlich
ist sprechen wir dazu mit Anne brül in
der Ukraine und unserem Moskau
Korrespondenten Armin Körper der gerade
im russisch besetzten Mariupol ist
zuerst zu ihnen Armin wie überzeugend
ist die russische Version dass die
Ukraine das Flugzeug abgeschossen
hat die russische Seite tut viel um zu
überzeugen auch international so hat z.B
Außenminister lavrov heute schon den UN
Sicherheitsrat um eine Sitzung in dieser
Angelegenheit gebeten mir stellen sich
da aber trotzdem noch Fragen z.B als
heute Nachmittag unabhängige Medien
melden die Maschine sei gar nicht im
Anflug auf belgerott gewesen sondern im
Abflug da hörte man aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium es habe eine
Zwischenlandung gegeben das macht aber
wenig Sinn weil die Grenze zur Ukraine
ist unmittelbar vor bjelgerat
auch stellt sich mir die Frage nach der
Zahl der Passagiere 65
Kriegsgefangene wurden da transportiert
darunter soll über ein Dutzend der
berüchtigten asofbrigaden hier aus
Mariupol gewesen sein und die sollen von
nur drei militärischen
Sicherheitskräften bewacht worden sein
da wissen wir aus anderen solcher
Transporte dass da eigentlich viel mehr
Personal im Spiel ist und last but not
liest heute ist der 700 Kriegstag auf
den Tag genau sind wir einen Monat vor
dem zweiten Jahrestag des ukrainekriegs
der Krem liebt solche Symbole und beide
Seiten versuchen dann natürlich ihre
Wahrheit und ihre Erzählung zu
verbreiten
Anne wie äußert sich die Ukraine zu dem
Absturz das Land wartet hier immer noch
auf eine offizielle Erklärung nur so
viel ist bekannt für heute war der
Austausch von Kriegsgefangenen geplant
er hat nicht stattgefunden sagt die
Ukraine sie selbst habe alle Bedingungen
erfüllt und habe ihrerseits aber auch
keinerlei Details von den Russen
bekommen schon gar nicht zur Sicherung
des Luftraums rund um belgorot das heißt
es gibt hier keine offizielle best
ätigung des
abchusses keine Details und auch kein
Dementi die Ukrainer vermuten ja S300
Raketen an Bord dieser Maschinen das ist
der Raketentyp mit den die Russen aus
dieser Region belgorot immer wieder die
zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine harkiv
angreifen und wenn an Bord dieses
Flugzeugs tatsächlich ukrainische
Kriegsgefangene gewesen wären wäre das
natürlich eine Tragödie für die Ukraine
aber es gibt viele Stimmen hier im Land
die warnen davor voreilige Schlüsse zu
ziehen und die sind auch bereit durchaus
russische Desinformationen in Betracht
zu ziehen vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Anne brühle und Amin
Körper nach Deutschland wer in den
nächsten Tagen Zug fahren will hat
mitunter schlechte Karten denn die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL streikt
wieder schon seit gestern Abend gibt es
Stillstand im Güterverkehr seit heute
morgen 2 Uhr zusätzlich im regional und
Fernverkehr andauern soll der bisher
längste Streik der Gewerkschaft noch bis
Montagabend ein notfallrplan ist
eingerichtet laut Bahn fallen 80% der
Fernzüge aus Sven rieen
berichtet da sind sie wieder die leeren
Bahnsteige die leeren Gleise der
Hamburger Hauptbahnhof leer gefegt wie
der Fuhrpark der Autovermieter wer heute
einen Mietwagen suchte zahlte selbst für
einen kleinen Wagen 428 €. wer doch die
Bahn nehmen wollte brauchte Geduld und
Verständnis ich glaube solche Dinge löst
man Verhandlungstisch und nicht mit
[Musik]
diesen Aktionen nach außenhin erscheint
es sehr nach einer privatfede zwischen
den beiden Vorständen die wenigen
Reisenden am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof
konnten immerhin sehen wieso die Züge
nicht fahren ein paar Gewerkschafter
zeigten Präsenz wir werden tausende von
Abgängen haben altersbedingt und um
diese Lücken werden des Fachkräfte
mangels zu füllen müssen wir die Berufe
im Eisenbahnbetrieb attraktiver machen
und da ist die 35 Stunden Woche einer
unserer Knackpunkte die Knackpunkte sind
derzeit fester verzurt als die Ladung
auf den stehenden Wagons auf Europas
größtem Rangierbahnhof in Maschen den
neuen Vorschlag der Gewerkschaft von
gestern Abend bezeichnete die Bahn als
Wiederholung altbekannter
Maximalforderungen wir haben gestern das
Ergebnis der Tarifverhandlung mit 18
Eisenbahnverkehrsunternehmen der Bahn
mitgeteilt als mögliche Kompromisslinie
die Bahn weiß das sofort zurück unter
der Überschrift geht nicht im Moment
geht also gar nichts Stillstand auf und
abseits der Gleise wir sind auf die GDL
zugegangen auch im Thema
Arbeitszeit und es gibt sicherlich wenn
man über Angebote spricht auch noch ein
Spielraum nur man muss erstmal
miteinander reden mit dem Streik der GDL
und dem Streit mit der Bahn ist es wie
mit den Mietwagen alles wird unplanbarer
und damit auch teurer Sowi der Wagen für
428 € heute genau das gleiche Modell für
den gleichen Zeitraum beim Anbieter
kostet in einer Woche gerade mal ein
Zehntel und der Streik der
lockführerinnen und Lockführer trifft
nicht nur Reisende sondern auch die
Wirtschaft hart Güter werden nicht
transportiert das führt zu
Lieferengpässen und verursacht Kosten
den gesamtwirtschaftlichen Schaden
schätzen Wirtschaftsfachleute beim sech
Tagen Arbeitskampf auf bis zu eine
Milliarde Euro Markus wer mit den
Details Güter gehören auf die Schiene
damit wirbt die Bahn Tochter DB Cargo
doch wenn die Züge stehen wird es teuer
die Bahn so die Aussage des Konzerns
kostet jeder Streiktag 25 Millionen Euro
der gesamtwirtschaftliche Schaden
weitaus höher das IW Köln schätzt 100
Millionen Euro pro Tag 6 Tage Streik
könnten rund eine Milliarde Kosten ein
sechageestik ist nicht das Doppelte
eines dreitageestiks sondern die Kosten
die Probleme in den Unternehmen die
Probleme auch bei allen von uns steigen
überproportional an die Industrie den
Streik viele Lieferketten sein ohnehin
angeschlagen ist der Streik noch
verhältnismäßig juristisch ist die Sache
klar das Streikrecht ist kaum gesetzlich
geregelt die Richter entscheiden häufig
zu Gunsten der Gewerkschaften die
wirtschaftlichen Schäden spielen so
verrückt das klingen mag erstmal keine
Rolle wenn ein Streik nicht auf die
Existenzvernichtung des Gegners abzielt
dann ist das weitgehend irrelevant doch
politisch wäst der Druck auf die GDL für
Verkehrsminister Wissing ist der Streik
sehr wohl unverhältnismäßig Herr welski
ist nicht bereit den Verhandlungstisch
zu betreten und deswegen brauchen wir
eine Mediation oder noch besser eine
Schlichtung und zwar so schnell wie
möglich so kann es nicht weitergehen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden in
geißelhaft genommen das Land gelehmt das
he keine Form der verantwortungsvollen
Wahrnehmung verfassungsgemäßer Rechte
wie es in dem Konflikt weiter geht hängt
auch davon ab wie gut die Streikkasse
der GDL gefüllt ist trotz Nachfrage
keine Antwort
wann geht ein Streik zu weit und was
sagt das Streikrecht dazu darüber reden
wir in der ZDF heute live mit einem
Arbeitsrechtler und einem Gewerkschafter
um 19:30 Uhr in unserer App und auf den
Social Media
Kanälen man nennt es
gsteigbelästigung radikale
Abtreibungsgegner protestieren vor
Beratungsstellen gegen
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche für Frauen die
eine solche Beratungsstelle aufsuchen
müssen wird der Gang zum
Spießrutenlauf doch die Beratung ist
eine Voraussetzung für eine straffreie
Abtreibung das Kabinett hat jetzt einen
Gesetzentwurf beschlossen mit dem Frauen
besser geschützt werden sollen Dorte
fber
berichtet so protestieren sie regelmäßig
vor der
Schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung in
Frankfurt jede Frau die zu einem
Gespräch kommt muss an den
Abtreibungsgegnern
vorbei seit
2017 werden wir regelmäßig heimgesucht
und
äh ja müssen damit umgehen in den
Beratung fühlen uns natürlich auch als
Beratungsstelle im Fokus natürlich
beeinträchtigt uns das sehr Schwangere
unter Druck setzen direkt vor Arztpraxen
und Beratungsstellen das Ziel der
Protestaktionen die Stadt Frankfurt
hatte mehrfach versucht das zu verbieten
erfolglos auch die Ärztekammer
unterstützt ungehinderten Zugang für
Frauen die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
haben es mit teilweise radikal
auftretenden Aktivisten zu tun die in
der Nähe von Praxen teilweise wochenlang
demonstrieren nötig ist dass dies
konsequenter als bisher verfolgt auch
strafrechtlich geandet wird Proteste in
höher und Sichtweite von Praxen sollen
künftig als
gsteigbelästigung gelten und mit
Bußgeldern von bis zu 5000 € geahet
werden können natürlich ist es nach wie
vor Teil des Rechtsstaates in
Deutschland dass auch
abtreibungsgegnerinnen und Gegner sich
können aber ihr Recht auf
Demonstrationsfreiheit und
meinungsfreiheit endet eben genau da wo
das individuelle Recht von Frauen
tangiert ist das Recht auf Beratung in
einer Konfliktsituation ohne Belästigung
auf dem gewieg
davor wer wird in den USA
Präsidentschaftskandidat der
Republikaner auch die zweite Vorwahl
dieses Mal in New Hampshire hat Donald
Trump jetzt klar gewonnen aufgeben wir
seine Konkurrentin Nicki Haley trotzdem
nicht hay war unter Trump
unbotschafterin jetzt ist sie seine
Rivalin Claudia Bates
berichtet schon früh am Abend verkündten
die Fernsehsender den Sieger Trump
suchte in New Hampshire die
Vorentscheidung und er hat sie
bekommen er bleibt der klare Favorit für
die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur die
Überraschung ist ausgeblieben doch Nicki
Haley verlässt nicht demütig die Bühne
sondern sie greift Donald Trump frontal
an mit Donald Trump gibt es nur Chaos
dieses Gerichtsverfahren jene
Kontroverse dieser Tweet man kann bidens
Chaos nicht mit republikanischem Chaos
lösen sie gibt sich
kämpferisch dieses Rennen ist noch lange
nicht
vorbei Trump sauer dass sie vor ihm ihre
Rede hält vor allem aber dass sie
weiterkämpft er antwortet mit
HME wer zur Hölle war die hochstalerin
die gerade auf der Bühne stand und
sprach als hätte sie gewonnen sie war so
schlecht sie hätte hier gewinnen
müssen Haley gewann die Wähler der Mitte
deutlich aber die republikanische Basis
war ganz klar bei
Trump die Basis ist genau da wo sie sein
will und Nickis Problem ist sie hat
keine Strategie um diese Basis zu
knacken doch auch für Trump ist das ein
Problem denn für die Präsidentschaft
braucht er auch die gemäßigten Wähler
der Mitte der Zirkus zieht weiter mit
Trump als Chef in der
Manege und aus Manchester in New
Hampshire ist uns jetzt Claudia Bates
zugeschaltet Claudia eine weitere
Vorwahl hat Trump also gewonnen in den
Umfragen liegt da auch deutlich vorn
warum macht Nicki Haley trotzdem
weiter also die Präsidentschaftswahl ist
immerhin noch ein dreiviertel Jahr
entfernt im November und bis dahin kann
noch viel passieren Trumps Kandidatur
ist ja begleitet von Skandalen
Gerichtsverfahren wegen eines
Umsturzversuchs nach der letzten Wahl
wegen der Mitnahme von hochgeheimen
Dokumenten also es ist denkbar dass er
bis zur Wahl ein verurteilter Straftäter
ist sein Alter ist auch ein Thema und
für diesen Fall dass Trump noch stolpert
positioniert sich Nicki Haley und
überhaupt als Zukunft der
republikanischen Partei allerdings
dürfte selbst dieser Weg für sie steinig
sein denn sie hat sich nun so K gegen
Trump gestellt dass sie dessen Anhänger
nicht mehr wird auf ihre Seite ziehen
können und so zeigt die Wahl hier
insgesamt sehr deutlich die Republikaner
sind eine gespaltene Partei gespalten in
trumper und sogenannte niemals trumper
was eine Herausforderung ist denn bei
der Präsidentschaftswahl brauchen sie
beide dieser Gruppen um zu gewinnen
danke schön für diese Einordnung Claudia
Bates zum Nahostkonflikt mindestens 210
Menschen sollen in Gaza bei israelischen
gffen bin 24 Stunden getötet worden sein
das berichtet die von der islamistischen
Hamas kontrollierte
Gesundheitsbehörde in Israel haben
tausende Frauen einen raschen Deal zur
Freilassung der rund 130 Geiseln
gefordert die noch im Gasastreifen
festgehalten werden an dem landesweiten
Tag des Zorns blockierten die
DemonstrantInnen Straßen und Kreuzung in
Tel Aviv heifa und
Jerusalem jetzt nach Argentinien das
heute lahm gelegt ist denn dort
protestieren gerade die Menschen in
einem Generalstreik gegen die Reform der
Regierung dabei ist Präsident jahwi may
gerade mal ein paar Wochen im Amt der
Rechtspopulist will Argentinien das in
einer Dauerkrise ist radikal sanieren
hat beispielsweise Staatsausgaben
gesenkt Subventionen gekürzt die eigene
Währung den Peso abgewertet jetzt wächst
die existenzangt bei den Menschen und
der Druck auf der Straße Antoine
kurschigen
sie sind aus ganz Argentinien nach
buraneseires gekommen um ihrem Ärger
Luft zu machen tausende protestieren
lautstark gegen die Reformen des neuen
Präsidenten auch Penelope Laumann ist
bei dem Generalstreik dabei die
41-Jährige arbeitet für das
Justizministerium viele ihrer Kollegen
haben in den letzten Tagen ihren Job
verloren und auch Penelope fürchtet um
ihre
Arbeit ich bin alleehende Mutter nicht
zu wissen was morgen passiert ob ich
noch Arbeit habe wie ich meine Familie
ernähren und Miete zahlen kann wegen
dieser Unsicherheit demonstriere
ich durch den neuen Wechselkurs ist der
Peso gegenüber dem Dollar nur noch die
Hälfte wert so sollen Exporte günstiger
und argentinische Unternehmen wieder fit
gemacht werden für den internationalen
Wettbewerb aber auch Gehälter und das
Ersparte das viele Argentinier wegen der
hohen Inflation in Dollar anlegen sind
damit nur noch die Hälfte wert und
gleichzeitig explodieren die Preise eine
Packung Reis kostete früher 1000 jetzt
fast 4000
Pesos es gab schon in der Vergangenheit
Preissteigerungen gleichzeitig wurden
aber die einommen angepasst das ist
dieses Mal nicht
passiert die Dynamik der argentinischen
Gesellschaft wird den neuen Präsidenten
zwingen seine Politik zu ändern ich
denke seine diktatorischen Neigungen
werden sich nichts
durchsetzen dass die Politik des neuen
Präsidenten am Ende weniger radikal ist
als seine Sprüche das ist auch die
Hoffnung der Demonstranten heute in
burnosirires jetzt kommen wir zum Sport
und nor beginnt ja heute mal nicht mit
Handball sondern mit Tennis ja denn
Alexander s der läuft bei den Australien
Open gerade zur Topform auf Sieg in
einem hart umkämpften Match gegen den
Weltranglisten zweiten Carlos alkaras
der Hamburger trifft am Freitag im
Finale auf Daniel
medwedieev schnell aggressiv präzise
zwerev startet überragend gewinnt die
beiden ersten Sätze 61 und 63 im dritten
führt er 5:2 bevor alkaras nach zwei
Breaks den Satz doch noch im Tiebreak
gewin er findet auch immer Wege aus aus
sehr schwierigen Situationen er hat auch
sein Spiel so ein bisschen geändert und
klar irgendwann fängt man auch so ein
bisschen nachzudenken im vierten Satz
wieder ein überlegener kein überlegender
zwerf der Hamburger gewinnt 6 Z4 und
damit das Match gegen Halbfinalgegner
Medvedev hatte eine negative Bilanz
sieben Siege
Niederlagen und auch ein deutsches
Doppel steht im Halbfinale der
Australien Open und das völlig
überraschend Dominik Köpfer und Jannick
hampfmann sie besiegten Hugo nice und
aus Monaco und Jan zilenski aus Polen in
zwei Szen ja und noch einen deutschen
Halbfinaleinzug könnte es heute Abend
geben bei der Hand Handball EM in Köln
dort trifft das dhbteam in gut einer
Stunde auf Kroatien schon ein
Unentschieden würde fürs Weiterkommen
reichen die gute Nachricht aus dem
Teamhotel rechts außen timo kastening
ist wieder fit nachdem er gegen Ungarn
wegen Grippe fehlte auf mögliche
Rechenspiele wie sie auch bei einer
Niederlage oder einem Unentschieden
weiterkommen wollen sich Goller und Co
gar nicht erst einlassen wir haben alles
in der Hand um um diesen riesenaum
Halbfinale im im eigenen Land zu
erreichen von daher wird es was ganz
besonderes für uns alle gegnerro ist
schon ausgeschieden will sich aber nicht
sang und klanglos von dieser EM
verabschieden ich freue mich auf dieses
Spiel geile Stimmung geile Atmosphäre
wir werden alles geben dass wir gewinnen
auf jeden Fall Bundestrainer Alfred
geslon hat ganz sicher gewarnt den
schwächenden Gegner nicht auf die
leichte Schulter zu nehmen und und
sollte Deutschland weiterkommen dann das
Halbfinalspiel gegen denemark Freitag
Abend live bei uns im ZDF sehr schön
danke na und diese Lottozahlen wurden
heute gezogen die Gewinnzahlen laut 9 10
19 29 35 39 Superzahl ist die 1 weitere
gewinnzeahlen finden Sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 nach Sturm und Orkanböhen heute wird
es morgen deutlich ruhiger mehr zum
Wetter gleich von Katja hornifer
christian siers hat um 21:45 Uhr das
heutejournal für sie auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute gab es orkanböh auf
dem Brocken im Harz 143 km pro Stunde
auf dem Großen Arber im Bayerischen Wald
131 und auf dem Feldberg im Schwarzwald
123 km pro Stunde dieser kräftige Wind
lässt jetzt im Laufe der Nacht nach auch
auch die Schauer werden weniger am
längsten regnet es noch am Alpenrand und
auch die kommende Nacht ist sehr mild
die tiefstemperaturen liegen zwischen
10° am oberrein und 2° in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und morgen erwarten uns
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen Werte um
5° am Rhein und westlich davon wird es
sehr mild bei 9 bis 13°. in
Norddeutschland wird das morgen ein
freundlicher Tag besonders an der Küste
werden sie häufiger die Sonne zu Gesicht
bekommen beimem Wind aus westlichen bis
westnordwestlichen Richtungen einige
Regenschauer gibt's noch im südlichen
Brandenburg und der lausit und von
Westen kommt schon der nächste Regen
heran und diese dichteren Wolken
verdrängen dann im Laufe des Tages
langsam auch die Sonne aus Bayern in der
Nacht zu Freitag und Freitag über Tag
wird dann das nächste Sturmtief uns
überqueren das betrifft vor allen Dingen
Norddeutschland mit dem kräftigen Wind
noch bleibt es mild das Wochenende wird
dann deutlich ruhiger und Kühler mit
Sonne Nebel und Hochnebel guten Abend